so as we mentioned collins is a prize
recruit for the rebels and has been a
star on the court here in the valley for
quite some time
ron futrell continuing our team coverage
with more on collins as a player
and profile here in las vegas yeah
denise this part of the story of course
pales in comparison
to the tragedy involved with this deadly
crash but zan collins was set to be the
future
of the unlv basketball program he was a
star guard who
led the bishop gorman basketball team to
three state
titles since he's been there he was
going to join the rebel basketball team
later this fall as a freshman
collins was part of a recruiting class
that was ranked 19th in the nation he
signed his letter of intent
to play for the rebels just last month
he was recruited by
every major west coast basketball team
usc arizona arizona state they were all
after him
he chose to stay home and play for the
rebels his future seemed pretty certain
now at just 19 years old
there are only questions the statement
from the unm athletic
athletic department is quote we are
aware of the tragic event that occurred
yesterday and are in the process of
gathering more information
our hearts go out to the families and
friends of those
impacted in a statement from zeon's
attorneys this afternoon
david chesnov and richard schoenfeld
they said in part
quote we ask that folks not rush to
judgment it's zeon's intention
to plead not guilty in quote i asked
about who owned the car that zeon was
driving a 260
2016 dodge challenger i was told that is
still being looked into denise